s-S-SOMEBODY TOUCHA MY SPAGHET!
(shits pants) Ohh, fuck!
Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to "SPAGHET".
Now you may be familiar with the meme (meme mode engaged) "SOMEBODY TOUCHA MAH SPAGHET"
Even though that meme is outdated, this game is a horror game.
Yes, that's true. I think, anyway. I actually don't know.
Let's play the game and find out, shall we?
oooo. "Look at the Spaghet to see the sl-"  (chuckles)
"to see the slap sequence."
"Slap the Spaghet..." (chuckle)
"by clicking the correct mouse sequence in the sequence."
"Complete the sequences to keep the Spaghet warm."
"Try to complete the first..."
[wheezes then starts laughing] WHAT?
"To keep it warm"?!
Somebody slappa my spaghet!
Why do I need to slappa the spaghet to keep it warm? Whatever.
(squishy noises, while Mark is quietly giggling)
[reading while laughing] "Each completed sequence increases the Temperature Meter above."
[reading] "If the Temperature Meter gets too low, the Spaghet will freeze!"
[reading] "If that happens, it's ALL OVER!"
"Press a to continue."
You got it, baby.
[reading] "If you click the incorrect mouse button in a sequence, you'll punch the  [laughing] Spaghet."
[reading] "This will cause the temperature to drop faster." [laughing]
[reading] "Complete the next four sequences."
[in-game slapping sounds]
Ah - ohhh. Ohh!
What happens if I..? *Laughs*
Oh, shiii- [laughing]
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry!
[in-game slapping sounds]
Ohhh. [laughing] Hya! Hya! Hi-yah!
Ooh! Ah! Ee!
Ooooh! [laughing]
Somebody... puncha mah spaghet.
This is a fetish I never even knew existed right now.
[reading] "In the top-right corner of the screen, there is a visibility meter."
[reading] "This meter fills whenever an unwanted spectator watches you."
[reading] "If the meter fills completely, you lose."
All right, let's avoid that.
[reading] "Look down at the arrow. Click left click to hide."
[laughing]
Oh, boy.
Oh, okay!
[reading] "While down there, you can't be seen by anyone on the other side of the counter."
[reading] "Keep in mind that you are still exposed on your side."
[laughing] Wha-?
[reading] "To stand up look at the arrows."
[reading] "In the event that there is a threat on this side of the counter, you'll need to hide on the other side."
[reading] "To do so look at the" ... "jump across" ... "try it out"!
[reading] "To return from that side, click jump back." Oh!
[reading] "Press a when you're back behind the original side of the counter to continue."
Oh, boy, it's so dynamic!
Ah!
[reading] "This concludes the tutorial. To see this view you can enable it in the settings menu. Press a to close."
Oh. Okay...
[in-game distorted yelling]
S-s-somebody TOUCHH MY SPAGHE-
[loud powering down noise]
Oh, FUCK!
Okay...
Oh, shit!
somebody did touchh my spaghet
[in-game slapping noises]
Oh...
Hey! Oh.
Sorry! I puncha da spaghet...
[in-game slapping noises]
*giggles*
[in-game distorted whispering] god dang it...
[in-game distorted scream]
OH! HI! HELLO! NO! AHH! JUMP ACROSS!
Mah Spaghet...
All I wanted- I am dead!
All I wanted to do was to toucha mah spaghet!
Oh boy. I'm rank 100.
[laughing]
Who's top 10? Who's top 10?
Ten seconds... that doesn't make any sense...
All right! Let's try again, shall we?! I guess! Let's do this.
SLAPPITY SLAPPITY SLAP.
[distorted in-game shout] S-s-somebody TOUCHA MAH SPAGHE- [powering down noise]
Somebody toucha mah spaghet!
All right, anyway. If we're going to continue this...
Let's slapper...
Slapper da pappardelle.
We're gonna, we're gonna slampingee this ...
li- lig- linguini.
[reading] "Don't let Mama see you."
I don't know-
Did Mama make this?
[in-game distorted voice] I see you...
[Mark] Uh...
Oh.
God.
Okay.
[in-game high-pitched ringing]
[in-game noise]
All right, I think that's probably the good sound.
Slappity slappity. Hmm
[reading] "Stay away from Goldie."
What about Papa Bear?
[in-game whisper] "Disgusting...."
Uh-oh. Ee--hehehe! [giggles]
Missed me, baby!
[slapping noises]
All right.
[reading] "Baby strikes what moves."
I move. What are you talking about?
[in-game distorted laugh]
O-kay... [laughing]
I ain't moving when I see baby!
What?
[reading] "Papa hates being watched."
Well, Papa no be watchy! Pappy gets...
[in-game distorted growling] "That... is... mine."
[thump... thump]
[high-pitched Markiplier noises]
[thump] [thump]
[whooshing noise]
[thump]
[thump] [thump]
[whooshing noise]
Um..
[in-game roaring]
AHH! OHH! PAPA!
PAPABEAR! PAPABABY!
BABY PAPA PAPA BABY! PAPA BABY!
[dissolves into giggling]
This game's tough.
Okay! All right then!
I bet I can do that again!
Everybody welcome to spaghet... *chuckles*
[in-game] S-S-SOMEBODY TOUCHA MAH SPAGHET! [powering down noise]
I think I read that wrong.
I think I got mixed up with Papa being something else, and...
[in-game whisper] Disgusting...
"DISGUSTING"?! What, me slappa the, the, the spaghet?
I'm pretty sure that it's not good for me either, but...
you know we can't all be beggars and choosers.
Slappy slappy slappy.
[distorted in-game voice] I'm WATCHING...
You ain't seen nothin, Mama!
Mama ain't gon' see nothin' here!
Okay. Slappa da spaghet.
Slappity slappity slap.
Slappity slappity slappa. Slappity slappa.
Woohoo. "Papa hates being watched."
Okay, this time I'm gonna watch Papa.
[in-game growling] "DON'T... LOOK AT ME."
I'm lookin'! Oh, I'm lookin' all right!
I'm ... Oh, oh, oh-
Gone!
Okay, so I assume that means you didn't want to be looked at,
but apparently I do look at you.
Left right left right right.
Slappy-
[in-game sound]
Ooh!  I'm not movin'! I ain't movin.'
[in-game growl] "DON'T... LOOK AT ME..."
Oh... Hang on...
Slappin', lookin'.
Lookin' lookin' lookin' lookin' lookin'!
I'm lookin'! Ooh, I'm looking.
Okay.
Oh, these - these slap sequences are getting complicated.
[distorted in-game voice] I see you...
Oh... Uh, uh-  OOH!
Okay that hiding meter don't go away.
Wait. That's, that's not fair!
That hiding weter- the hiding wiener don't go away!
I can't hide my wiener!
I can't, it's impossible to- OHSHIT!
oh shit. Okay.
[in-game whisper] "Disgusting..."
Not that disgusting!
I need to heat up my spaghet!
Hang on, wait! Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa!
Okay. Right, left, left, right, left, left.
Left, left, right, left, left, left...
Left right right right right right right left.
[distorted in-game voice] I'm watching...
Wrong! I thought you were gonna be Goldilocks... [shudder sound]
Okay.
This is gonna get compli-
Left, right, left left, right right, left
Right, left, right, left, left left right
Left left left, right right right right, left.
Left right-
[in-game growl] "DON'T... LOOK AT ME."
I'm'a look. I'm lookin at you. Hey buddy.
Hey Papa! Hey, Papa!
Hey, nobody toucha yo spaghet! Nobody ever touch-
left, left, left, right, right, right, right, left
[sped-up, indiscernible audio, accelerating]
[shouts]
Oh, oh, oh, that was a bit too close for comfort.
Okay.
All right. Left, right, right, right, left-
Oh shit.
[in-game] I'm watching...
No you're not! No you're not.
God, that's just... the global eliminator there.
Mama's always watching it!
I'm never gonna be able to get away from mama!
Just let me touch- slap my spaghet in peace, Mama!
You told me you'd knock before you come watch me!
You never know when I'm coming to slap my spaghet!
[in-game] I see you...
You don't see shit. No.
[in-game growl] "THAT IS MINE."
Mama! Mama!
Mama, I'm a growin' boy!
Hang on, wait, I'll be right with you, Papa.
There we go. Hang on.
Papa, no.
Papa, no, no no no no no no. Papa no. Papa no. Papa, no!
That's right.
Nope that was wrong.
[in-game whisper] "Disgusting..."
Not THAT disgusting.
Oh, man. I'm gonna lose it.
I want to get past five minutes.
I need to-
[in-game whisper] "Disgusting..."
UH-OH-
UH-OH!
DOUBLE?!
No?
Okay, all right, all right...
Left, right,  left- Let me slap!
Let me slap!
How can I slap if you be so bitch?
Left, left, right, left, left, left, left-
No!
right, left, left, left, right-
[in-game] "I see you..."
NOPE!
Okay, barely any, barely any.
But my - oh, my spaghet's sittin'- is getting so cold.
I don't know how hot my hands could possibly be
if slapping this spaghet is going to work...
[in-game whisper] "Disgusting..."
SHIT! Okay, we got charger.
I don't know why Goldilocks is calling ME disgusting.
Goldilocks is the one that came in to a house full of bears...
and decided to ruin everyone's day.
[in-game] I see you...
OH!  [incoherent noises]
[shriek] OH! HI!
Oh, Mama!
Mama, why?! Mama?!
I did pretty good, though. I did pretty good.
I'm not gonna lie, I did  pretty good.
I wanna see what happens when I die from everybody. I don't think there's a way to actually
[in-game] SOMEBODY TOUCH MY SPAGET!
OHHHHHH! I don't think there is a way to actually
Win this I think this is gonna be me slap until the end of my days hey baby baby this womp
Hey baby! OH SORRY! OH! Oh my God! My HEAD!
[Mark.exe stopped working]
Ah
Am I on the leaderboard though
Wait no, but I slapped real good, but my slaps
How can I saw I okay?
Ah
Welcome to Amber skull so Amber skull is actually an interesting game I found on Steam that contains
Four different horror experiences you've got the blizzard
You've got the forest you've got ocean and you've got abandoned so the first one. Oh, I have to do the first one here. Oh
Oh...
Can I do...?
Can I shift... oh no I have to oh I
Guess we have to start with the blizzard, so we're gonna go with the blue...
Oh ok! Hey. How's it going there?
[static] OH!
Hi! Hello. Where am I?
OH
I'm in a box or I'm in a cage or I'm in a chimney
I'm Santa I'm Santa stuck in a chimney, and this is how many days I've been trapped here. Damn my perpetual life!
Uhhh... Oh!
Alright then I'm out
Okay, I'm back in I'm out, and I'm in
Oh!
Alright, I'm guessing. This is where I hide from whatever is happening out here
Probably hide oh boy.
Oh!
Ping bong shit, what about you I?
I don't know what any of this is but I got a bad feeling about it, okay, alright, so
So says you so says me. Let's go to it. I guess I gotta follow the blink blonky light. I cannot run far at all
Okay, it's getting dark. I don't like that
Well can't run for shit
[screech] Oh!
Oh!OHOHOHOH! OK!!
[SCREECH]
AHHHHHEY! ABBOMMIBUBBLE SNOWMAN!
[thudding footsteps leading away]
Okay see ya alright. Okay? We have that to worry about look it okay alright
[laughing] I don't understand
What that was or why that was but it was a good teaching lesson to know that I wasn't close... AH!
Oh you dick oh you dick you're gonna be dickish to me
Huh righty-ho I guess I gotta follow these out and try to power up
Whatever the hell that is maybe this is some kind of rocket that can get me out of here
Blast me off back to the mainland. It's my only assumption here, otherwise
I'm just gonna be boned around walking in the middle of the freezing desert with nothing to my name
I'm guessing I did spend enough days trapped in that little...there's another one
[Snowman thudding]
Oh oh OHH Hey WHOA WHOA WHOA
hey
This one's got a planet oh, this one's got a little planet on it. Oh I made them please okay
alright.
Well
C'est la vie I made it through that I don't know what else is gonna be waiting for me out here, but
I don't think I needed to do that. I didn't hear a thumpiwump so I'm guessing I'm fine. That's not good
um. uh.
Problem problem problem um problem
uuhhm
Problem
Problem!
We're in trouble, I don't know how to get across or down. Ooh, I know how to get across an tower down
All right
This is good. Oh, I was just about to say it seemed safe. I was very wrong. my heart
Go thumpie thumpie boop out of my head
Okay
right.
okay! wi- whouh oh. [thumping sounds]
wELL [thumping sounds continue]
Hope you fall down and die okay, I guess he's not gonna do either of those options
All right, thank you. Thank you very much for that
all right cool
*uneasy noises*
Anybody? did I hear I love you. Oh, okay. I forgot that you just walk into it
okay! everything's fine!
Wonderful, I'm doing great
So that's it. This is a cool thing about this game
If there's four different modes with apparently different mechanics for each one that are brutally spooky
I don't know if it counts as one game horror game or four
AH!
ugh, STOP IT! STOP IT MY HEART!
*various sobbing noises*
why would you- [thumping noises] uh oh, uh oh. Go--no--go forward
[thumping intensifies] *distressed noises*
uh, there's a little guy-OOOH
[snowman screeches and loud game noises]
I'm sorry for everything that I have done to offend you
Alright, well. okay, okay.
One last one.
I mean the threat of death seems to be pretty not
Immediate. I mean. It's immediate. There's a big ol Yeti after me, but it seems like there's plenty of safe zones to possibly hide in- uh oh
um.
[thumping noises] *various distressed noises*
No I can't run AAAUGHHAH run run run run please run, okay, all right?
[snowman screeches, loud game noises]
Sorry
[thumping]
Okay
All right, so I guess I gotta try to traverse the snowy terrain
By myself with no help of cord
o-okay. alright.
okay
it..oooh. aah. Snowman-AAH
Stop! Stop! just stop it! just stooop!!
It's not cool
Me old heart can't take it. Me old Pirate heart. Oh there we go. all right. That's good. That's
Grand actually, that's grand
God I'm feeling comfortable again. I feel as if nothing's gonna come out and jump scare me
I sure hope..I sure hope nothing do cause that would be...that would be just a big ol pile of poop
oh
oh i got lost again, got no one in front of me or beside me. Oh there we go found the cord
Man I cannot run very far. I guess it is winter, and I'm probably wearing a lot of equipment.
[thumping noise]
Oh, oh don't care going going going going run more little more, please
AAAAAAHHH
[snowman screech, loud game noises]
That was close. I made the right call by going back for it
I made the right call I made the right call I made the right call
Made the right call dickhole
All right
eye-yaye-yaye-yaye
This guy means-UAHHH
*sigh*
Why why why?
why?
Hey, I found the bunker
Hey guys I found the bu--oooh. [loud alarm]
uh oh oh oo
oh uh uh ooh uh
Okay
um..oh.
oh no. oh
[noise of door]
oh
Okay, I don't know what happened. I think I hit the button and it... warded it?
I think? okay! all right!
*increasingly distressed noises]
It's fine. I don't like how everything goes dark whatever I run
also I have a funny feeling that the the base is actually just very very close
And I'm running counter Wampus to everything I need to run to
[thumping]
nope, nope, nope nope nope nope nope nope
What? huh? wha? huh?
Wha?
Oh is that?
you thumpy thump no?
You no thumpy thump real hard. okay I found a cable. I don't know if it's the cable oh
Wait there it is okay
I'm very close. I've almost got this I think. I don't know what I've got but
I think I've got it. okay here we go. I'm gonna push the button. gonna push the big bing bong button  I pushed the big-oh uh oh
[loud thumping] * more distressed noises*
[loud screaming and music]
We won?
Yay
That went a lot better than expected. I'm sure I'm glad the Yeti climbed on top of my giant laser cannon
huh
Okay, I don't like that okay. It's perfectly innocent sounding, but let's go stay in the light. Okay, all right
We're gonna stay in the light
Something tells me that the force is not gonna-augh oh oh oh okay
oh
ah
Flaming dildo okay? Oh
that looks
problematic
Giant rat man apparently. Oh do I have to burn the forest down? Oh my god. It's a dream come true
Whoa you think that that fire would produce more light
I can't see anything
oooooh-ooohkay. wha-? [loud static sound]
ah
oh. ah. oh
[loud screaming and noises from game] *screams*
Oh wow, wow, wow!
What I
Didn't I don't know what the hell, huh?
Okay
That didn't make any sense. I was trying to stay in the light, then there was no light, and then I didn't stay it actually
Didn't actually stay in it
Okay, now I have light. now I have some light, but I didn't have light before for some reason it was gone just
kind of
There now I have
I'm trying to go okay you see how I have no light
Whoa, okay; I'm gonna go back. Let me go back with this light, and I can see things.
Okay, I got... I got light. I gotta go I gotta go
Light that - okay, all right, I lit that that was nice
Oh, go go go
Ah
It's a dead end. I'm gonna go back go back
uh oh uh oh uh oh Oh OH OH
Light! Okay precious precious sweet light
Okay, I hate this. I hate this. This is a different words than any other words, I remember
Not like this is- uh oh. [game screams]
All right okay let's stay in the light. Alright let's go. Let's go for it. I think it's randomly generated. Hi, okay
*Mark noises* Pretend I've done nothing!
ooooh highdy-highdy ho
highdy highdy ho
All right
*laughs* it's totally fine...it's totally fine!
let's just let's just burn this down
Okay, alright don't see anything in the woods that time. That's great. Okay. All right cool.
I don't know okay, both are dead ends both are dead ends. Go go. Go. Go go back back back back back
I don't like being out of safety! I don't like being out of the safety of a light
the warm, comforting light
the light is nice
the light: real nice.
alright let's go
*nonchalant singing* la da-da
deedlie-deedlie-dee
Okay, that's gonna take some time. I'm gonna go back while that's burning
There's nothing to be panicked about in this forest everything that can harm me probably won't harm me
That's the solace that I take from this
Go go go please. Go you're working your oh oh
alright. okay. OOH!
Good
Good, I heard that from over that way, so I won't be going that way definitely not
Let's try it this way
Okay so far so good so far so good so far. So yes. Hi hello. Oh
It's the Witch of the woods it's the Blair Witch
That's not so bad. I'm not gonna go that way though that seems like a bad way to go. that seems like the wrong oh
*panicked and distressed noises* (lots of uh-ohs)
No no no NO!
[loud game scream]
Hello okay, all right we you don't need to do that we don't need that we don't need that
We just don't need that. I know we don't need that is all what I have to say about that. bridge!? That's new
Um is it good? Do I go across the bridge, or is that just instant death? I'm gonna guess it's not instant death
[loud game noises] *Mark distressed*
Okay
Hover bad
Mium know when water bad water real bad mium no go near water mium not go near water well good fire
Me no like water water no good
Some people say water good me say no water no good. alright. Okay. I don't like any of these choices hmm, okay?
um
let's, uh
Let's try one of these let's try one let's try one okay?
Not that one not that one not that one let's not go that one that was bad. That was bad. That was bad
I didn't like that one anyway, maybe let's try behind the rock the secret one behind the rock seems like
That's good. Nope never. I'm not good. Not good very bad. Actually very bad very bad very bad, okay
You know what I had a good feeling about this one down here on the Left
I had a great feeling about this one, so let's go
Okay, still good still good still good still good still good still good. Oh, so good
So good my heart is thumping thump real good, but it's okay
Only one way to go after this oh no
here we goo!
Okay, left just guessing okay. Oh shit
Oh shit going back going back going back going back going back going back. Yes made it. Okay still alive
We burned down the pile. I'm assuming. That's the way that we need to go now
Okay here we go
Go go go go go. Oh my god. So many splits No oh no. No, I'm going back. I don't care how far it is
I'm just gonna go back.
No! I should have gone forward!
this one's so hard
I guess ill just-
NO GOD I FORGOT TO CLICK NOO!
auugh I forgot to click! AHH fuck!
There's got to be the right way to go up here. I just burned a pile
Go go go go. Go. Go. Go. Go. Go. Go. Go. I don't know where it's going and sleeping back. Oh fuck oh
Fuck oh no no no no no no no no no no no no oh no come on
ah uh ah ah ughhhh
Don't like you. I don't like when you do that to me. It's like a looping back and forth bullshitty woody
But at least I burned a pile. I think I did
Let's go. Let's try to follow that but I have no idea which way that went
C'mon c'mon c'mon. please yes. Yes, okay. Oh, yay hello, mr. Fungus man, okay, alright, so
This is probably the farthest I've made it. I don't even know how with this goddamn
Okay, big pile alright big pile yay
oh oh oh OH OH OH OH
[triumphant game music]
That worked out quite well for me, I didn't think it was gonna and then it worked out, Oh good
They all they just like to just jump-
[alarm going off]
Unit. Unit? Unit.
Okay
All right, well that was game two of the three games
Let's try ocean which I'm probably going to hate "Hold signal collect." Oh!
I'm probably gonna hate this. okay! All right at least It's not based on random chance, Hopefully.
Oh boy. Oh, no oh
I can move my boat, okay, but why though?
What's at the front of my boat? Where am- Oh, no I hate it
I hate it, this is the worst thing I've ever seen
Light! Okay.
Okay, I'll go towards the light cuz I've got nothing better to do with my life.
Just know there's gonna be a giant Megalodon shooting a shooting up out of the
Ocean any time now. What is you? Its a buoy. Okay.
Nice bouy. Do I hit-
*gasp*
Um...
Oh, I'm out of gas oh
[sound of water swishing]
I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I hate it.
*thunder*
OH! Oh, i hate it. I hate it. I hate it.
I don't know what to do! How do i get my-
*gasp*
What was that?
Okay did it, i think?
[loud game noises]
Why? what did I do wrong?
I mean, I just sat there for a long time, but what did I do wrong to you?
I didn't even know how to start it up again
I didnt know how to start it up!
I hate that I can't look behind me.
Uh oh.
Okay, that's easy enough I now know how to start it again
You just hold and...
Click and hold and let go when it gets in the green
Huh, okay, okay, okay, okay, all right, you don't need to do that
You don't need to do any of that to me. I don't understand how the mechanics work of this just yet.
Rock! uh oh.
Rocky waters. Do we go into it? I guess, I'm guessing we go into it
Hey, maybe the monster will have a tougher time trying to get us if we just go into this. I think.
maybe
Okay. I dont know..
Green! my favorite-
Waaiiit a minute
Wait a minute!
there we go- AHAH AH aH
I don't know if the buoy's gonna help me at all. Let's just eat one more. I think
Okay, where could it-ding!- Okay? Where could it possibly be?
HEY! It's a green!
uh, ding dong!
Yay, I think when I get there, I'll be game over and I'll get to go home and everything will be fine
[game beeps] boo-boop!
what? oh
Okay, I'm going towards something. all right not sure what that's slower
No hey don't do that okay, so over here, it's faster towards it oh
Well there we are
[water splashes]
No please I don't think you need to be anywhere near me right now
Whatever's behind me does not mean could be anywhere near I'm gonna make it in here. We're gonna be fine. Oh
Okay, I don't know what is this mean? What did I do okay? I can't start it back up again. I don't know what this means
[loud noises] HOOOO
what the fuuu?
[loud game noises continue]
what the (mouths fuck)
[loud noises]
Okay
[triumphant game noises]
I win? I think I won
[different triumphant game music]
yaaaaaaah hoooo!
Right we get to go to whatever abandon is oh?
Listen flash check alright. I'm ready to flash my tits if I could do that if it means I don't die
I'll flash pretty much anything. I got oh no oh
No, oh that kind of flash. Oh
I don't like it already
ooooh boooooy. oh boy oh boy oh boy
It's like five nights at frumpies in here
oh oh bdbodbobd is that blood?
[loud game noises] *Mark yelling*
No idea what I did wrong
Was the blood bad?
Was the blood bad does the blood mean bad?
Did the blood mean bad?
Is B for bad blood for bad
Let's not do that
Maybe
What's with what whoa
Hey, that's good listen listen listen listen listen listen listen listen. Okay. I will listen listen listen listen
Okay
Okay all right
Well I can't tell anything
No open
[loud game noises] *Mark yelling*
But i was listening!
It's just a bat! it gets in my hair
Okay, then guess we gotta listen huh, oh why is why is it? Why why?
Nope nope no no no. No.
HAiiiiy *laughs*
Who came up with this sadistic game who made this sadistic game, it's not abandoned oh
Okay, there's a light over there
Haaaaa-*nervous laughter*
I almost died. I almost choked.
Okay, I don't like the way - oh.
I don't like the way the movement goes. Ah. Hate that. Hate that. Hate that?
Oooh!
Got that. I don't know what that does, but I got it. I got a beep boop.
Okay, all right.
What am I looking for again, and why why am I looking for whatever?
I'm looking for I don't know what I'm looking for why am I here? Why would I be here? Why would anyone be here?
What's... what's the point of all this?
Why is it running like a potato?
Why is it capturing - oh shit, hi. Okay, all right.
I don't know why it's going in cinematic 24p, but okay. Whatever, you know.
I guess this is just how it is.
Am I fine?
That's blood, I'm not gonna. Let's let's not b for blood. Oh
Blood here too. Okay, is there another door? Good.
No blood? No blood means fine, right?
Yeah, it's fine. Yeah, okay. I think I got the recipe
I saw blood. I saw blood.
No blood!!
Ah, no blood. No blood! So it's either blood, or sounds. I don't know what what for oh right in here. Okay? Why?
Why? Also why run like potato? Why get two frames?
Please have more frames. Please. I know this is it
Holy shit, okay
*MaRkiSCrEaM*
Okay, I guess I go this way. Okay, great great great great great great great.
Okay. Slightly less potato-y frame rate in here. Still pretty potato-y.
I wasn't sure if that was the noise or not!!
I wasn't sure okay. Let's turn down the graphics on that particular level. All right. Let's do this
Listen listen listen. I can't see shit. Well. This is the worst. I can't this is graphics are
I gotta listen. I gotta listen, hang on. Let me try,
Try high? Okay. Let's do high all right. Let's do high. Let's, let's get high (Oh, oki)
Okay all right, okay?
Noooooooooo, but I thought if you faked me out  it wouldn't be there. How can I hear it if you fake me out?
I didn't see any blood though! I didn't see any blood
Maybe I'm not close enough to hear it. I need to get farther on the threshold
Blood blood blood
See shit, okay sometimes that just happens, so let's go down to this one
Sometimes that just happens apparently. okay five
uh oh. noise.
Why
I didn't hear I couldn't hear what the fuck
Alright here we go. I think this is gonna be the last one
Alright we've narrowed it down!
I can't hear shit on any of them. I've got no ears on this
No no blood Hey oh-oh-oh go
away go away go away. Yes, please whoa. What is this?
what is this?
ooo AAAAH
YEEAAAH
[triumphant game music]
YAAAAY! I DID IT! I DID IT
Okay
So man [game: is the sweetheart you married the husband you expected him to be? Has the war created new problems for you in your marriage?
To answer these and other personal problems brought in by your friends and neighbors
Herod presents John J
Anthony founder of the famed marital relations Institute in a brand new program of daily sessions of kindly and helpful at night] what?
[game: Just as Mr. Anthony , by example...] Okay I don't need
marriage advice, I'm gonna play this, it says play me.
I don't know what this is, but i'm gonna play it hello ooh. Nope don't like this oh
Hello hi am I getting a new job. Oh, that's a little oh, oh it's a bunch of simulations
Us the oculus rift testing facility Hey wow?
These are really cool. What do they do?
Oh, No
How did someone gulag me
Please don't strap me into one of those
I don't want to relive experiences or I don't want you to suck out my brain
is that what happened people sucked out their memories and put them onto these tapes, and that's what I was reliving I
Think I'm being dragged, but I'm not hung up since you're oh
Oh, no no don't suck out my brain
Not my brain my precious brain come on man. Oh, please. I don't wanna
Ow squeak Oh
OOOOOW
No, okay, well there goes my brain hello, oh
Okay, all right what's happening calibrating? Oh?
What do I do trying to move, but there's no move okay, oh, hi hello, how are you?
[VERY LOUD GAME]
Did I make it out? am i better? this is-- oh shit, can't move
No, I guess everything's all for the good now. Everything's hunky Dukey. Oh yes
Right oh
Oh there. We oh I'm up. Oh. I'm up. Hey. I'm up. Okay. Well. Can I straighten that out again, No all right?
Well, then that's good. I got that from wherever I got and I live in a shithole, but
All right, oh, let's get out of here then no never mind. Let's not let's pick this up. No
Let's not let's look at this no let's not
Hello
Um was that a gunshot probably yes
Okay should I be worried about this, or is you who?
You're trying to break down my heart, I'll open it for you
[loud game music]
Okay
That was cool. I'm dead okay. I'm dead alright. Well. That was still cool
Except for that happening, but that was cool
There's no joke really really cool four games in one plus another game
That's not bad. Well. Thank you Charlie B hem for making this Ben
Behan. Behan.
For making this and thank you everybody so much for watching. This was a really cool one love this a lot
I liked how it was diverse the forest one was a little bullshit
But I'll forgive that one the other ones were still pretty cool, but thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below if you've got more scary games that you want me to play
Let me know in the comments as well. Thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh-Bye!!
[outro music]